chuckle I lost my little brother who
died in a random medical accident he was
someone that I always looked after how
do you deal with grief and loss of men
in your command someone asked me a
similar question that the other day
someone along the lines of how gonna be
good
when you lose a loved one and that's
definitely a tough question and I almost
replied no it isn't good there's nothing
good in death and and then I started to
remember the people I've lost throughout
my life the memories of them the
experiences the fun their unique
personalities and everything they've
given me not only in their life but in
their death what their life taught me
and what their death taught me the mark
the mark they had left on me and I
realized I realized that even in death
even in death there is good first of all
I was lucky to have that person in my
life even if it was only for a short
time too short of a time but at least I
got that those unforgettable moments
those precious moments at least I got
those and I got to experience those
times to know of the beauty of their
personality their attitude their outlook
on the world
they were all unique and I'm thankful
for the opportunity that I had to
interact with them even if it was just
for a short amount of time and now comes
death death is horrible and death is
wretched and death is cruel and death
isn't fair and I don't know why the best
people seem to get taken from us first
but the fact is death is inescapable
there is no way out in
death in that death is part of life in
like the contrast between the darkness
and the light without death then there
is no life and the people that I've lost
they taught me that
they taught me how precious life is how
blessed we are to have every day to
learn and to grow and to laugh and to
live to live to live every day with
purpose and with passion to wake up in
the morning and be thankful thankful for
that morning and thankful for the
opportunity to go out into the world and
live to live for them for those that
don't have the opportunity for those
that were stolen away by deaths cruel
hand for them I will live I will cherish
their memory and I will live so let's
cry no more let's mourn no more let's
remember but let's not dwell instead
let's laugh and let's love and let's
embrace and cherish everything that life
is and every opportunity it gives us
live